we interrupt this program to bring you
Courage the Cowardly Dog
fandom as a pup he was found by Muriel
whales in the middle of nowhere with her
husband Eustace Bagge ah but creepy
stuff happens in nowhere stupid dog
you made me look bad
my name is Pierre back to sunny with
Pierre back first time and probably not
this very last either but
welcome to Sundays with pity fights
usually fridays with pewdiepie if you're
new and it's supposed to be my weekly
check-in with you bros my subscribers
see what's up
sir everything is you know good down
there I don't know why your baby you
live underneath me that's why I meant um
I'm sorry I didn't have time for Friday
or Saturday pewdiepie I had a lot of
busy busy days these days if you notice
I don't make it Friday goodbye or
anything like I like it trust me I'm
trying the hardest to actually do it
like it's not like I'm just too tired to
do it like if it's not showing up it's
simply because I can't do it it's it's
without a my power even though I am
pretty power as always there's been a
lot of stuff going on this Monday I was
in a parade I was like part of the jury
and I met a lot of you bros there was a
lot of fun meeting you and taking
pictures and whatnot so I don't know if
you ever seen you somewhere like really
don't be scared to say hi or I don't
know as to take photo or whatever you
want to do again it's it's not something
I just yeah I don't know if you see I am
more than happy to take
and do it it is a lot of you are like is
it okay if I talk about of course it's
okay to take a photo I I would love to
so that's that's that I guess I met so
many bros these days it's ridiculous
like I I just go outside and I mean a
couple bros but it's a lot of fun it's
something I never thought would happen
but I'm glad it did I'm glad it did next
week me and my girlfriend Mozza would be
in LA from Wednesday to Sunday I'm not
sure if I'll just I could do like
scheduled uploads or whatever but it's
not really my style to do that I don't
know them actually sense it's just I
prefer to have like a daily thing where
I make the videos I don't really like to
do them in advance and then upload them
or I could just be there and enjoy the
time I'm there I don't know what to do
to be honest but I'm really looking
forward to go to LA it's thanks to
YouTube that I got this opportunity so
thanks YouTube maybe there's a couple of
LA bros that i can meet there I don't
know um also this summer there's a lot
of like events and stuff like that I
will go to I will try to go to Dreamhack
it's not set in stone yet because I will
be in Italy and then Spain and then
played a little bit a little bit so
there's a lot of other events too that I
will go to so and this summer will be
busy for sure for me but I'm sure it
will be a lot of fun
alright so I also forgot to mention I
yesterday I was in not news I was in a
TV sitting show and a lot of you bros
wanted to see my house and I pretty much
show my house in the in the thing so I
thought it might be interesting for you
to watch ha ha
the vocal mean I heard how having some
go awry Oh Cydia having our shark it's
hitting in oh they have something I'm
flat sick
you're humming neat and a holler are in
dr. I think they'd like me to make a
breeze and so there was even this one
guy who was analyzing me which I thought
was pretty funny I was that was it to
spell out door to spell the portals
later he'd feel like some but in today I
know you stand up this is a total lame
PewDiePie party but okay I'll roll with
it
hey hiya Dan you come here after the
effects Valley kill never lisanna has
Moffitt are a newcomer lucuma no hockey
no meseta grandpa door to nil Allah then
perfectly some PLL [ __ ] alright so that
was pretty much it for this week's
Friday goodbye to unwrap it over the
breakfast I'm talking with them but I
don't have enough hands I'm shy very
professional of me I know right
anyway it stay awesome bros and i'll
keep making videos for you that's very
much a chairman activate